[Music]
I just say haven't seen that kind of
wave in a long time that's a little kid
leaving on a bus way yeah it's the
Muppet wave like you know I had my son I
take he gets on a school bus every
morning huh he does a thing where he's
eight he'll hug me and he'll say goodbye
dad goodbye and I'd be like goodbye Sun
goodbye as good to see you and then he
starts to go for the bus and he comes
back and hugs me again and I'm like oh
that's sweet he always does it to it
then he gets on the bus and as he's
going up the steps he turns and he's
like yeah that's very dramatic I know I
think people used to have dramatic
goodbyes because they wouldn't see each
other for three years yeah because yeah
they had no planes or anything yeah that
makes total sense I'll see you in nine
years all it was very dramatic later
wife John Adams said goodbye later one
later wife I'll see you when I'm 90 how
only I want to I want to congratulate
you
skeleton twins the biggest the most
talked about movie at Sundance which is
hard to do because there's so many films
that are getting some buzz or people
trying to get them some buzz at Sundance
and skeleton twins the movie that you
co-star in with the lovely Kristen Wiig
is at the top of every list everybody's
talking about this movie so
congratulations thank you very much
never I've never been to the Sundance
Film Festival insane it's just a minute
you get there you're doing tons of press
and it was just me and the director
Craig Johnson doing everything cuz
Kristen Wiig got sick she got sick yeah
we didn't get go and so I was like she's
faking she just doesn't wanna I called
her and I was like Kristen Kristen come
on and then she you know and she
answered the phone and she was like ello
oh I'm sorry yeah it sounded like
something from the neverending story or
[Laughter]
zzzz does she have I don't know but it's
all over Silverlake now ty burrell is in
this movie - yes Ty Burrell Modern
Family he's such a funny guy he is a
funny guy he and I in this film play
ex-lovers and we have a pretty they cut
it from the movie but we had a pretty
hot makeout scene and the anti Burrell
do in the film so you you two actors
made out for the movie and then they cut
it I cut the move they cut it out of the
movie which really bummed me out I call
ty and I was like remember that
wonderful night we had together
well they cut it and then we shot the
that scene and then I got home and my
wife is a huge ty burrell fan she has a
huge crush on him the minute I walked in
the room she gave me a huge kiss and
said that's the closest I'll ever come
to kissing time around and I did it Jack
Benny take a look at the sad